we have this from Taylor Hansen uh
tenant media shout out he tweets as I'm
on my way home to Salt Lake City Utah I
notice six illegal immigrants are also
boarding the same American Air flight
looks like I've got some new neighbors I
want to pull up uh I'll pull up the twet
maybe they maybe they've pinned it I
don't know where uh okay tenant covering
all the caucus stuff there's a video
that oh holy crap Iran is allegedly
launching attack on a US Consulate in
Iraq is it well th those were the
original reports but the Iranians are
now saying that they're attacking a
rebel group that is against Iran inside
of Iraq so far we have not gotten any
confirmations that us targets were uh
picked out here w wow C oh and for Vi
was hitting another caucus site so he
may be much later well we have this
story from tenant media this is crazy we
should definitely talk about this
pertaining to the uh us elections last
night tenant reporter Taylor USA
confronted multiple satx police working
a side gig where they are helping
facilitate human smuggling at the
migrant Resource Center in San Antonio
Texas the officers are seen wearing
their official sapd uniforms driving
work vehicles and holstering their
service weapons while accepting money
from alleged cartel sponsored NOS to
guard the facility and check illegal
migrants wristbands upon entry we tted
to reach out to satx police for comment
on the situation and received no
response this story is massive it's got
2.3 million views just on the single
tweet alone and this is what I was
talking about the fear of what happens
when law enforcement is f is is
committing crimes what happens these are
these are what is it San Antonio police
using police and publicly funded
Vehicles weapons and and and and uh
equipment to help facilitate cartel
alleged cartel human smuggling
operations we got that report just uh
last week the doj is suing Texas because
Texas deployed armed soldiers to block
CBP access to the river you now have a
bubbling conflict between corrupt law
enforcement facilitating human
trafficking and smuggling and law
enforcement at the state level trying to
stop it where does that
go I I I defer to the states the states
have a duty to defend themselves right
but what do you think happens if the
federal government doesn't back down and
what do you think happens if Nicki haly
wins it's interesting conundrum for the
federal government hopefully their their
their goal is to support states rights
ideally is is cohesion and you don't
want to press the states away and also
they're dealing with geopolitical
nightmare with this like you're talking
about the houthis what's going on in
Ukraine and Israel all these things
hopefully the United States do not push
the issue on this I mean Texas made very
clear okay what does that mean the
United States they are actively
facilitating human smuggling into this
country and have been for several years
the charts show that it is there's no
way it's an accident the rates are
double triple or quadruple what they
were under Trump and under Obama so it's
on purpose and the only state doing
anything somewhat is Texas while the
other states do nothing kind of made me
think about the American Civil War I was
thinking about the Emancipation
Proclamation and how Abraham Lincoln was
like Hey all you slaves in the South
you're free and kind of like and by the
way if you want to fight for the north
go for it all these illegal immigrants
if the federal government were like hey
all the all you illegal immigrants you
can have citizenship if you want to
fight for the federal government if you
know what I mean kind of thing like if
there's a just to like disincentivize
people from trying to create some sort
of Civil War in the United States we
talk about this quite a bit on the show
but we have you here Benny I'm curious
your thoughts on the on this border
issue right you've got state level
fighting with Federal officers to the
point where they're armed soldiers
deployed against federal law
enforcement so so all of this goes back
to the 1960s cloward and Piven and the
Communists who sort of wrote the Neo
Marxist vision for America and how to
bring Marxism to America and one of the
number one things you needed to do was
uh balloon the welfare state large
enough so that it actually collapses the
federal dollar and the federal
government's capacity that's that's the
number one way to create crisis America
would never be conquered this was after
World War II so how do you actually
bring down a behemoth like America how
do you bring down the you know the Beast
that is America you have to destroy it
from within you have to give it a a some
type of uh horrible malady and something
that is so insufferable that it can't
move forward and so their idea was swell
the welfare roles which you saw with the
Great Society program uh swell the
welfare roles so big that the federal
government can never afford it and then
that will create of course the
millstones of high taxation and
inflation that that grind the middle
class and you get no middle class and so
this the way that you swell the welfare
rules is to bring people here that have
that don't speak the language that have
no skills um that can't get jobs or are
having a tough time you know or or can't
work legally uh but are accessible are
able to get on welfare programs and
California is leading the way in this
and that's the way that you actually
collapse the United States of America I
think that's the ultimate strategy here
a lot of people are like well they'll
vote Democrat I think F yes maybe yes
but the real goal is the collapse of the
country as we know it and that was the
vision set out by the theorists the com
the Marxist theorists Neo Marxist
theorists who are Barack Obama are the
acolyte is the acolyte of do you think
that they're making this decision to let
these people in on accident that it's
like toxically compassionate or are they
actively trying to destroy the country
it's not compassionate it's child
smuggling this is the most horrific
thing that a man a human being can do to
another human being I it's awful What's
happen I guess but once they hit the
Border they're like at this point
they're here the idea like but we can't
turn them away that that kind of why
can't you turn them away I mean you can
other country every other country in the
World Turns away I mean go check out the
border with Egypt and Gaza but but it's
but it's not just that and that is true
the Egypt and Gaza is a great example
it's not just that it's a uh why the US
doesn't pay Ransom to terrorists in the
Middle East it it it is it is well known
for the most part I don't know Biden may
have changed some of this that if you
are traveling around I don't know Syria
or something and you get kidnapped and
you're an American citizen the people
who kidnapped you no the US doesn't pay
they send a bunch of heavily armed dudes
from a from a Blackhawk in the middle of
the night to kill you and anyone in the
building with you but European countries
will pay the ransoms instantly what
happens if you're Spanish or German
you're a huge Target you if you're a
journalist from Spain or Germany a
national and you're traveling around the
Middle East they are looking at you you
you cost $4 million they know like
that's the guy to get then there's an
American next to him they go not that
guy you they'll just kill you if if the
US is basically saying borders open if
you're here I guess you're here what
happens some dude Honduras goes well if
I go there they'll let me in might as
well go if the if the strategy was we've
blocked it off turn around good luck
you're on your own not our problem guy
in Honduras be like there's no point in
traveling A Thousand Miles they're going
to turn me away that's why I call it
toxically compassionate it's not real
it's like compassion to a fault like we
can let everyone in it'll be okay it's
not compassion it's the opposite of that
and and to Tim's point the CIA usually
gives the money upfront to the
terrorists um and then that's usually
how they get their cut they don't rely
on uh on you know killing people and and
and kidnapping them they just get the
money up front uh but but but if you
look at what what's happening here again
this is a deliberate plot here this is a
deliberate plan to not just create
future Democratic voters but there's a
larger bigger agenda here that has been
weaponized against the American people
that is causing division that is causing
strife I think a lot of this is planned
I think they're trying to get as much of
it done before this next election cycle
because they know this is going to be
one of the key issues that they're going
to be recalled for and when they do they
want to make sure they have enough
people here for whatever reason some
people say we need military fighting age
males to fight China or Russia some
people are saying we might need these
males to fight the other faction inside
of the United States may be a part of
take a drink Civil War that could
potentially happen as well there's
different theories out there but the
theories are legitimate because it's not
for the benefit of the American people
in any way you you kind of look at
it the possib ility that the Biden
Administration invokes the Insurrection
act against Texas for blocking federal
agents at the border uh I would defer to
the constitution on this so it's the
federal government's job article 4
section 4 uh article one section 8 of
the US Constitution to protect the
states from Invasion however when you
jump to the 10th Amendment the 10th
Amendment says that if the federal
government is failing their own
responsibility and the article doesn't
say that the states cannot be can cannot
take up the responsibility then that
responsibility can be taken up by the
states or by the individuals and that's
that's really key I think that we're
going to start seeing some some really
interesting what if under that argument
of section article four section four the
Biden administ Administration says we
are protecting the Border by having our
troops our our our CBP and our our law
enforcement at the border and Texas is
blocking us from enforcing our
constitutional duties thus engaging in
Insurrection uh Ken Paxton has an 80%
win rate against the the Biden
Administration so he's pretty pretty
probably one of the smartest people on
the Constitution that I've ever come
across so yeah but we're not talking
about the like the legality of it Norms
are breaking down the idea that the
Texas National Guard was deployed armed
to block access to federal law
enforcement the concern there is at what
point do both sides assert jurisdiction
over the same area and when that happens
who's going to try to arrest the other
or or does this really just come down to
Biden Administration just backs down
instantly and says we don't want to
fight we lose you win this is exactly
what happened in Fort
suner the kick off kick kicked off the
Civil War like an argument over a
military base where like a localized
militia like started fighting federal
forces the Union forces were occupying
Fort Sumpter the after the secession
South Carolina said you are not welcome
to be here leave the Union forces were
like it's our base we built and paid for
you can't succeed it's illegal we're
staying and I think the only actual
death in that conflict was an accidental
death on the side of the Union I could
be wrong uh his I read a bunch of
Articles saying no no one really knows
who fired the first shot but I'm simply
saying territorial dispute or like
Federal jurisdiction is what kicked off
the Civil War like what it's seen as
historically kick off and here but
here's the here's the best point after
that we historically look back at that
date and say that was the start of the
Civil War however the actual first
bloody battle was the first battle of BU
run which even after the battle at Fort
Sumpter local residents in the area did
not believe Civil War Could Happen even
though we believe it already started and
picnicking watching the first bloody
battle which was chaos so we look at
this border issue this jurisdiction
issue and perhaps that's it perhaps all
we get is a standoff which is happening
now already with federal law enforcement
Texas National Guard and we think
nothing of it and even after some CBP
guy shoves a National Guard guy and then
they try arresting someone and we're
like wow they're fighting we still don't
think we're in it and then maybe after
this Texas deploys armed National Guard
to the border to block a bunch of Biden
vehicles that are trying to come in
resulting in actual shootouts and then
we say 100 years from now it started
when the Texas National Guard deployed
armed soldiers to block federal agents
from facilitating human smuggling or
whatever thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net